En este video hablaremos sobre el muestreo
aleatorio del que ya hemos hablado en otros
videos, y vamos a comparar lo que ya sabemos
sobre el muestreo aleatorio simple con un nuevo
tipo de muestreo aleatorio que presentaremos
en este video. Y este es el muestreo aleatorio
sistemático. Veamos un ejemplo. Imagina que
realizamos un concierto y que esperamos que
aproximadamente 10 mil personas asistan al
concierto. Ahora bien, queremos muestrear
personas aleatoriamente en el concierto, tal
vez queremos hacer un estudio sobre cómo llega
la gente al concierto: ¿cómo llega la gente
al concierto? ¿Conducen y estacionan su auto?,
¿viajan con un amigo?, ¿toman un Uber o algún
tipo de taxi? Para esto queremos encontrar
una muestra aleatoria idealmente sin sesgo para
hacer una encuesta. Así que hay un par de formas
de hacerlo. Podríamos intentar tomar una muestra
aleatoria simple, y ese podría ser el caso si de
alguna forma pudiéramos obtener los nombres de
las 10 mil personas y ponerlos en un tazón muy
grande como este, y luego, digamos que queremos
muestrear a 100 personas. Digamos que queremos
muestrear aproximadamente 100 personas, entonces
podríamos mezclar todos los nombres que pueden
estar en estos 10 mil pequeños trozos de papel
y luego extraer una muestra aleatoria de 100
de ellos. Esa sería una muestra aleatoria simple.
Pero podemos imaginar que hay algunas dificultades
logísticas al hacer esto: ¿cómo vamos a conseguir
los 10 mil nombres? Tendríamos que escribirlos en
una hoja de papel y mezclarlos bien para que la
elección de los nombres sea realmente aleatoria.
Entonces, ¿existirán otras formas de tomar una
muestra aleatoria? Y como puedes imaginar sí,
los hay, y ahí es donde resulta útil el muestreo
aleatorio sistemático. Una forma de pensar en el
muestreo aleatorio sistemático es muestrear al
azar un subconjunto de las personas que tal vez
estén entrando al concierto. Digamos que la
gente llega al concierto y empiezan a formar
una fila para ingresar. Lo que queremos hacer
en el muestro aleatorio sistemático es elegir
al azar a la primera persona, y hay muchas formas
en las que podemos hacer eso. Digamos que tenemos
un generador de números aleatorios que nos dan un
número del 1 al 100, y esa será la primera persona
a la que encuestaremos. Si ese generador de
números aleatorios nos da el número 37, entonces
comenzaremos con la persona número 37 en la fila.
Así que elegimos a esa primera persona al azar,
la encuestamos y, recuerda nuestro objetivo es
tomar una muestra de 100 personas de 10 mil, así
que queremos encuestar aproximadamente a 1 de cada
100 personas. Entonces, lo que haremos es que,
una vez que tenemos la primera persona a la
que vamos a muestrear, a partir de ella vamos
a muestrear otra persona cada 100 personas. A eso
se le conoce como intervalo de muestra. Y la razón
por la que son 100 personas es que si muestreamos
a una de cada 100 personas a partir de la primera
muestra, obtendrás aproximadamente 100 personas
en tu muestra de un total de 10 mil. Entonces,
después de 100 personas vas a encuestar a alguien
más, y luego después de otras 100 personas vas a
encuestar a alguien más. Ahora la razón por la
que esto es útil es que podemos decir: "Bien,
la primera persona fue aleatoria, y al igual
que cada persona después de ella, no parece
que haya ningún sesgo al elegir a la centésima
persona después de la primera encuestada". Ojo,
no queremos encuestar a las primeras 100 personas
porque ellas pueden ser las que llegaron temprano,
pueden ser las primeras personas que consiguieron
estacionar su auto o quienes planificaron desde
antes su llegada al concierto, es decir,
una muestra que tenga algún tipo de sesgo,
así que queremos asegurarnos de que estamos
obteniendo encuestas tanto al principio,
en el medio y al final de la fila, y esto
nos ayuda. Ahora, debemos tener cuidado,
incluso el muestreo aleatorio sistemático no es
infalible. Inadvertidamente hay una situación en
la que incluso este muestreo tiene sesgos. No
sé, digamos que esta es la sede del concierto,
esta es la vista superior de la sede del concierto
y esta es la fila de las personas que entran;
y supongamos que aquí es donde estás parado y
estás contando cada 100 personas. Pero tal vez,
supongamos que hay un árbol justo aquí, tal vez
haya un camino por acá, digo, estoy haciendo esto
bastante elaborado, pero imagina que tal vez haya
un camino justo por aquí y muchas personas -quizás
todas las personas que caminan o toman un taxi-
vienen en esta dirección, y tal vez toda la gente
del estacionamiento venga de esta dirección, y
tal vez haya un oficial de policía aquí mismo
que esté controlando la multitud, tal vez él
deje entrar a 50 personas de un lado, seguido
de 50 personas del otro. Bueno, en esta situación,
al tomar la centésima persona, podríamos terminar
muestreando sólo un lado o el otro, por lo
tanto debemos asegurarnos de que no se está
introduciendo algún tipo de sesgo en esta fila,
ya que eso podría distorsionar nuestra muestra.